[Music]
my name is derek wengee i am the
director of sneaker operations at the
cobblers in miami florida
today we're going to be soul swapping a
original 1985 pair of
jordan chicago ones with the donor sold
and these actually released in 1985 with
a retail of just 65
for reference the same pair in 1985 for
65
is now in the aftermarket brand new for
about twenty thousand dollars and that's
if you can even find a pair
[Music]
the first step that we need to do is
acquire a donor shoe in this case the
client had provided a donor shoe which
is actually the 2015 retro which is
merely just a re-release of the shoe
on this particular pair the customer
requested that we leave the upper of the
shoe which is all of the leather
he did not want it cleaned he did not
want it painted he didn't want any
conditioners
so we need to carefully take off the
sole without you know damaging the sole
or altering anything in this case the
upper of the donor shoe
is not as important but sometimes we'll
use those parts for other things
so what i like to start with is just
using heat and acetone ideally i'll pour
the acetone inside of the shoe to
actually loosen up the glue
that is on the footbed and the side
walls of the shoe to kind of break that
down to give me an entry point in the
side
once we're able to get to that layer of
stitching on the side walls we can then
use
an exacto knife as you see i'm using
here or you can also use a seam ripper
to undo those stitches
once the the side wall and stitching is
undone it should be pretty easy from
there we can either just pull the upper
apart or continue using heat or the
acetone to break up that glue
to separate the sole from the upper ear
it's a similar process to remove the
original upper from the sole if it's not
already detached in this case there is
stitching here as you can see
however we don't want to use excess heat
and we also definitely don't want to
pour acetone into the shoe as that would
damage the upper of the original
on the sides here you'll see that i use
a bone folder which is just
bone from an animal it's just a not a
sharp edge but a blunt enough edge that
i can open up the side walls to get down
into that stitching there
once the two pieces are completely
separated we are going to remove
all of the dust and crumbling inside of
the original shoe as well as from the
upper to prepare this
upper of the original shoe to be put on
the donor shoe
[Music]
we use a contact cement it is made for
shoes it is flexible it's clear so it's
perfect for what we're doing here
and it's very important with any type of
restoration we do when we're working
with glue especially in this case
that we get a clean surface and get that
fully prepped and all of the old glue
any dust or any buildup oil water that
may have seeped into that shoe
the reasoning for this is because if we
don't have a clean surface for the glue
to adhere to the glue is not going to
fully do its job in holding that shoe
together for the longest period of time
we will apply one thin layer to the
upper in this case as well as on
the sole of the donor shoe and we allow
that to dry
a tip that i like to use is actually to
let this glue over here so it gives me
more
time to fit the sneaker as opposed to
having to put it all together in one
shot
and this again is so we can line up the
upper properly on the sole so there's no
distinction
between the original muscle and the
donor sole being lined up on this 1985.
[Music]
once we've heated up the glue and
pressed it with our hand to make sure
everything is fitting properly
we will then just double check and make
sure everything is lined up the way we'd
like so everything looks original
we'll then take the original last from
the shoe which is
just the interior of the shoe if you can
think of it as what shoe makers use to
make and shape
shoes go place that into the shoe and
then we will take it over to the bladder
press what the bladder press is going to
do is basically give us that extra
security and push the shoe together
and make sure that the glue is fully
bonded and has a strong hold to it
once we're done you can see here that we
actually stitch by hand there is a
machine but with something this delicate
and this
fragile and rare we actually prefer
stitching it by hand just so we know
that every stitch is fit perfectly into
the original hole
to make things look as original as
possible as you can see this isn't a
pure white thread we're using we
actually have an
age or more of a vanilla cream thread
which is going to match the original
look of that shoe
if we were to put a bright brilliant
white lace or thread in there
it would kind of take away from the
originality of keeping the upper a
little distressed
and having the soul looking brand new on
top of an old distressed 1985
shoe we actually add a little bit of wax
here to imitate the original shoe upon
[Music]
release
now that everything's stitched up it may
not be mind-blowing before and after
just putting a sole onto a new shoe but
to us in these little details this makes
the shoe complete and i think the
customer's going to be very happy with
these results
[Music]
[Music]
you